العاصمه الاوكرانيه اكياس بلا كهرباء وماء
وتدفئه بعد هجمات موسكو على البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه والثلوج تهدد بمزيد من
المعاناه للاوكرانيين الحراره في البلاد
دون الصفر والتدفئه غير متوفره في ظل
انقطاع الكهرباء الذي طال الملايين
الاشخاص على واقع استمرار القصر الروسيه
الوضع في اكياس صعب جدا حتى الساعه
وانقطاع الكهرباء مستمر على الجميع وعلى
جميع استخدام الكهرباء بحدود تقول شركه
تشغيل شبكه الكهرباء في اوكرانيا الشركه
اكدت ايضا ان منتجين الكهرباء تمكنوا من
تغطيه ثلاثه ارباع احتياجات الاستهلاك فقط
مما استلزم فرض قيود وانقطاع الكهرباء في
جميع انحاء البلاد الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
اكدت ان سته ملايين شخص انقطعت عنهم
الكهرباء بعد احدث عمليات قصر روسيا
الاسبوع الماضي والذي الحق اسوا اضرار حتى
الان بكره يعني هو ادى الى ترك الملايين
بلا كهرباء او ما او تدفئه الرئيس
الاوكراني فلودي ميرسيليسكي انتقد بشده
رئيس بلديه كاف بسبب ما وصفه لسوء ادائه
في انشاء ملاجئ طارئه لمساعده من يفتقرون
للكهرباء والتدفئه والتدفئه بعد الهجمات
الروسيه وذلك في خلاف عناني نادر بن زعماء
اوكرانيا المهندسون يواصلون السعاده نظام
الطاقه ولكن لا تزال القيود على الامداد
بالكهرباء موجوده في 15 منطقه في اوكرانيا
بما في ذلك في المقابل تكرم لن يقول ان
هجمات موسكو على البنيه التحتيه للطاقه هي
نتيجه لعدم استعداد
[موسيقى]